Haley what are your thoughts on Nikki
Haley running for president well I think
there's two things so I'm what I'm going
to talk about uh macro micro because you
know that's how I do it on the macro
level she has now come out and there's
more than just the sanus has walked onto
the debate stage there's now three
podiums Trump DeSantis and Haley this
opens the door for others to declare as
well
on the macro stage and so what that does
is actually helps DeSantis because it's
not DeSantis breaking Rank and saying I
want to run now it's multiple people and
it's like hey this is a primary this is
what we do this is the process so Donald
you're going to be on stage and uh
there's other people going to be there
so on the macro level I think this helps
the Santa's because it opens up the
field and it's not just Trump versus
DeSantis there's many people running the
second thing on the micro level I think
she's positioning for a VP spot oh wow
that's my that's my thought what do you
think that um you and I on the same page
with that I I think what they are doing
uh is exactly that yeah that's for me
it's exactly that uh uh they're they're
speaking very highly of each other when
you get on that stage the strategy my
opinion is the fact that Nikki Haley is
going to be the one to go after DeSantis
not Trump and digging a double tag team
and then eventually Nikki could end up
being a VP and by the way she she's a
very qualified VP if she ends up
becoming a VP some even thought at one
point she wasn't on Trump Camp because
she called him out on a couple different
things so this is you know this is a
very very strategy strategic thing
that's taking place it's going to be
interesting to see the Camp that because
there is a republican camp that doesn't
want Trump and there is a republican Cam
that only believes Trump's the one that
needs to finish up his second term and
fix everything that started either way
this is not what we're seeing strategy
taking place between the two it'll be
fun to see what direction the sentence
this was an episode I sort of got on
House of Cards where where uh Kevin
Spacey's character teamed up with
somebody else during a debate and I mean
I I see it all planned but dude honestly
I'm what just hearing you guys talk
about the stage and the well I swear to
God I would pay to watch I'm excited to
see that moment of DeSantis Trump and
her I think that you have seized to get
on board bro and just make it like
announce them and have them come in dude
I I would 100 put 50 bucks to watch this
but the first time I still need to put
our bed on but mind you that's going to
divide the party and then we mean you've
uh pay for what I think I think Tom hit
it on the head I think Pat agreed with
him she is full on auditioning for a
vice presidential role in the movie
called 2024. yeah there's no chance
she's being elected president of the
United States no okay my opinion hear me
I agree it's Trump or DeSantis that's it
okay by the way she ain't no like walk
in the park she's cunning smart smart
attractive enough to to basically hold
her own on the stage she was a governor
wasn't she the ambassador to the U.N
under Trump like she ain't no joke so
just House of card Style
she's got some stuff up her sleeve let's
see who she attacks let's see if she
Embraces and it's not just up her sleeve
it's between her ears um I I had that
privilege of sitting with her and with
um uh congresswoman Beth Van Dyne in
Dallas at a small gathering they were
trying to raise funds and stuff and she
was there to support Beth's campaign and
there was about 50 of us at this little
reception before the big reception you
know how those things work
um and somebody asked her to give a
breakdown of you know foreign trade
tariff no tariff and things and she went
for 15 minutes with one of the most
elegant dissertations and I'm like wow
not only does she know what she's
talking about she's in it and that was
when she was serving at the U.N so this
is also a very smart person that would
balance a ticket and she would play her
foreign policy cards and experience her
trade in the U.N her and DeSantis
unbeatable ticket her and Trump still
very beatable my opinion right you might
be right wait her and DeSantis
unbeatable ticket her and Trump
still to be yeah
because I think bottom line is this
we're talking about primaries we get it
there's so many Independents out there
there's so many you know conservative
Democrats who will gladly loudly proudly
walk into a voting booth and say I voted
for Ron DeSantis no doubt there's not
those many of those to Trump these days
I'm sorry but so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign